Snoopy and Woodstock's best moments from season 2.
Number 8: Let's join Snoopy and Woodstock on a train ride.
(Train engine)
(Choo-Choo)
Phew!
Number 7:  Snoopy and Woodstock  play hide-and-go-seek.
(Snoopy counting)
(Woodstock irritated)
(Snoopy sniffing)
(Woodstock happy)
Number 6: Woodstock finds some fancy new feathers.
Ohh! There's another one!
What does your book say about pink feathers?
I think it's either a pink feather nightingale
or a very short flamingo.
(Bird Chirps)
(Tree swoosh)
(Woodstock screams)
(Laughter)
(Woodstock falling)
Number 5:  It's Snoopy's turn to be fancy
on Beagle Appreciation Day.
(Gasps)
Is it Beagle Appreciation Day already?
May I say, you look very majestic in your crown.
Please accept to my shovel as your royal scepter.
(Clap)
All hail King Snoopy!
That is one regal beagle.
Ha ha ha!
Number 4: Snoopy and Woodstock play in the great outdoors.
Hi Snoopy. Where are you off to?
"Today, I will lead my brave Beagle Scouts into the woods."
"We shall enjoy the great outdoors
free from all modern conveniences."
No modern conveniences?
That is brave.
(Snoopy agrees)
Beagle Scout badge opportunity number 1:
identifying footprints.
(Birds confused)
(Snoopy growls)
(Snoopy irritated)
(Horn sound)
Number 3: Snoopy and Woodstock have an adventure in outer space.
(Laughing)
(Woodstock Panics)
(Snoopy and Woodstock cheer)
(Woodstock gasps)
(Snoopy grunts)
(Snoopy and Woodstock cheer)
(Warning alarm)
(Screaming)
Snoopy?
(Screaming Continues)
I thought you were cleaning?
Number 2: Schroeder gets some musical help from his feathered friends.
(Birds sing Beethoven's “Fur Elise”)
What do you think,  Schroeder?
(Birds singing continue)
Well, the pitch is off.
Would Beethoven appreciate it?
I'm not sure.
But I certainly do.
(Schroeder plays piano while birds sing)
And number 1: what will Snoopy do at home
when Woodstock goes on vacation?
It looks like your friend's going south for the winter.
I'm sure you'll find plenty of things to do while your friend is gone.
(Snoopy confused)
(Snoopy having fun)
(Buzzer Sounds)
(Snoopy is sad)
(Woodstock is happy)
(Snoopy surprised)
(Woodstock blows raspberry)
(Sighs of relaxation)